네. 안녕하세요. 어, 오늘은 제가
좀 색다르게 어, 이렇게 칠판에 좀
오늘 수익률 계산을 좀 해 볼
거거든요. 그래서 많은 분들이 되게
단순하게 계산하시는데 제가 칠판에
적어 드리면서 한번 좀 세부적으로
설명을 좀 드리겠습니다. 만약에 내가
건물을 40억에 사 가지고 100억에
팔았을 때 과연 60억이 남는지 아마
되게 궁금해하시는 분들이 있는데
기사로 좀 그런게 많이 나가요.
단순하게 그냥 40억에 샀다가
100억에 팔았다. 그래서 60억을
벌었다 이렇게 나가는데 제가 오늘 좀
세부적으로 진짜 얼마를 벌었는지 어
여러분들한테 좀 설명드리도록
하겠습니다. 어 우선은 다시 매입했고
그리고 예상이 이제 8년 정도 보유를
한 거예요. 그래서 40억에 매입할
때 취득세가 나갑니다. 취득세 뭐
대략 한 1억 8천 뭐 거의 2억
정도 나가요. 뭐 기타 중계 수수료랑
뭐 법무 비용까지 해 가지고 대략 한
2억 3천 정도 들었다고 치고 그리고
건물이 대부분 다 노화된 건물들이
많거든요. 그래서 뭐 리모델링 비용이
뭐 6억 5천 정도 들었다고 치고
매각할 때 또 중개 수수료가
나가거든요. 그래서 중계 수수료가
[음악]
뭐 0.9 구 받았다라고 치면은 대략
한 9천만 원 정도 나갑니다. 그리고
그 재산세가 나갑니다. 근데 여러분들
여기서 아실게 보통 주택을 가지고
있으면은 재산세랑 종부세랑 같이
내잖아요. 근데 어이 정도 규모의
빌딩은 종부세를 안 냅니다. 그래서
보통은 재산세만 낸다라고 보시면 될
거 같고 대략 한요 정도 규모의
빌딩은 1년에 보통 나가는 거 보면은
[음악] 한 1년에 1천만 원 정도
나가는 거 같아요. 그래서 만약에
8년을 보유했다고 치면은 한 8천만
원 정도 나갈 것으로 예상이 됩니다.
그래서 요거는 대략적인 금액이에요.
네. 그래서 뭐 재산세가 한 8천만
원 정도 나가고 거기에 이제 보면은
이렇게 해서 부수적으로 돈 나가는게
약 10억 정도 돼요. 그래서 나는
단순하게 40억에 사 가지고
100억에 팔아서 이제 60억 남는
줄 알았는데이 부대 비용만 거의
10억 정도 나갑니다. 네. 그리고
이제 50억을 만약에 벌었잖아요.
그래서 여기서 한번 좀 계산을 해 볼
건데 이게 개인이냐 법인이냐에 따라
또 달라요. 일단 개인은 5억 초과
같은 경우에는 양도 소득세가 무려
45%입니다. 네. 근데 지방
소득세까지 하면 49.5%예요.
5%예요. 근데 법인은 2억 초과
같은 경우에는 올해부터 또 세법이
조금 바뀌어 가지고 20%입니다.
그래서 그 지방 소득세량 다 합치면
22% 정도 돼요. 지금 거의 이것만
해도 차이가 굉장히 크죠. 근데
개인의 장점은 뭐냐면 장기보유 특별
공제가 돼요. 그래서 요게 만약에 뭐
8년 된다라고 하면은 16%입니다.
[음악] 그래서요 차액게 16%고
근데 법인은 장기보위 특보 공제가 안
됩니다. 근데 이게 안 된다 하더라도
세율 자체가 워낙 낮기 때문에
전체적인 금액으로 봤을 때는 법인이
훨씬 더 유리해요. 그래서 요렇게
계산해 보면 약 20억 정도
나옵니다. 법인은 10억 정도
나와요. 전체적인 금액으로 봤을 때
거의 한 10억 정도 차이가 납니다.
그래서 사람들이 법인으로 많이 매입을
해요. [음악] 근데 이런 질문은
굉장히 많이 하세요. 그래서 만약에
법인으로 해 가지고 이건 알겠어요.
예를 들어서 10억을 더 벌었어요.
근데 이거를 개인으로 뺄 때 또
세금을 내지 않냐? 이런 얘기를 많이
하시는데 법인으로 보통 매입하신
분들이 이렇게 돈을 다 빼진
않아요.이 돈 번 가지고 다시
재투자를 하거든요. 그게 법인의 또
매력이에요. 그래서이 프로젝트 하나
때문에 법인을 만들었다가 뭐 차익을
내고 이걸 다시 개인으로 돈을 빼
가지고 하는 경우는 저는 못 봤어요.
저는 못 볼 정도로이 법인으로
매입했을 때 장점들을 잘 살려 가지고
어 투자를 진행하고 그렇게 샀다가
계속 재투자하고 재투자하고 이게 약간
눈덩이처럼 불어나거든요. 그래서 그런
점 때문에 법인으로 좀 많이 매입하고
있습니다. 그리고 법인을 보통
설립하기 전에 가족 법인을 많이
만들어요. [음악]
그래서 자녀들한테도 미리 이제 주식을
줘 가지고 이렇게 나중에 증여라든지
[음악]
어 이런 부분에 있어서도 좀 미리
세팅을 많이 합니다. 그래서 무슨
일이 있었냐면 예전에 이렇게 많이
하니까 법인 유보금에 대해서 과세를
하겠다 그랬었어요. 근데 이게 반감이
되게 심해 가지고 물론 [음악] 안
되긴 했지만 그래서 나라에서도 보면은
유보금으로 가세를 한다고 할 정도로
법인이 세율적으로 봤을 때는 되게
유리한 거예요. 근데이 법인 투자할
때 또 주의해야 될 것들이 있거든요.
그거는 제가 다음 시간에 제대로 어
다시 한번 좀 설명을 드리도록
하겠습니다. 네. 그래서 오늘 좀
정리를 해 드리면 내가 만약에
40억에 산 건물을 100억에
팔았다고 했을 때 그냥 단순하게 시세
차액이 60억이 아니라이 지금
리모델링 비용이랑 취득세 뭐
중계수들을 다 합쳐서 기본 비용만
10억이 날아갑니다. 네. 20억이
날아가고 그리고 이제 나머지 개인이냐
법인이냐에 따라서 세율 차이가 굉장히
크고 어 여러분들이 아셔야 될게 어
나는 이렇게만 봤을 때는 60억을 번
거 같지만 실질적으로는 거의 한
30억 법인으로 하면 한 40억 정도
그니까 한 10억 정도 차이가 나죠.
네. 어, 이게 실제 수익이라고
보시면 될 거 같습니다. 그래서
이렇게 세금을 다 내고 비용을 다
내고 진짜 내 돈에 얼마가 남는지를
확인하는게 되게 중요하거든요. 어,
오늘이 영상을 좀 참고하신 다음에
내가 실질적으로 돈을 얼마를 버는지
어,이 부분도 체크해 보시면 좋을 것
같습니다. 그리고 다음 시간에 제가
법인의 장단점을 좀 자세하게 좀
설명을 드릴게요. 그래서 법인의 좀
단점들도 있거든요. 그래서 그
내용들을 한번 반응이 좋으면 어 제가
뭐 이렇게 좀 법인에 대해서도
자세하게 설명드리도록 하겠습니다.
오늘 영상 여기까지 하겠습니다.
감사합니다.